[Musique]
en février Morgane a décidé de changer
de vie cette Parisienne travaillait dans
un bureau d'études spécialisé dans les
télécoms après plusieurs années de doute
elle a choisi de quitter son poste
plusieurs fois j'ai eu envie de partir
chaque fois on a fait changer mon poste
si on m'a donné une nouvelle
responsabilité ce qui restait
intéressant mais pas suffisamment pour
pour me donner envie de
poursuivre dans un domaine qui
m'intéressait pas selon un sondage
réalisé en juin 34% des salariés
français sont en burn out soit trois
fois le niveau avant covid
complètement désabusé et semaine passent
tu te rends compte que ça fait six mois
et hop ça revient c'est un souci de
santé personnel qui m'a fait réaliser
que
enfin ça valait pas le coup quoi elle
cherche désormais une formation pour se
reconvertir et devenir libraire
comme Morgane François lui aussi
osé quitter son poste après 25 ans
passés en tant que salarié cette expert
en communication et en conseil s'est
lancé à son compte
de salariés donc voilà dans une boîte
dans laquelle j'étais depuis 12 ans donc
le risque était nul ou quasi nul enfin
évidemment quand on crée une boîte du
jour au lendemain le revenu est
complètement incertain c'est quand même
un grand saut dans le vide quoi ça c'est
sûr après un an et demi son entreprise
s'est développée et emploie maintenant
cette personne
avant de sauter le pas François s'est
appuyé sur un collectif appelé postadem
il a participé à une formation spéciale
pendant trois mois porteur de projets à
définir justement son projet il a tout
faire pour le faire exister réellement
Manon Gayet et coach pour postadem
d'après plusieurs centaines de personnes
ont déjà participé au programme
dès 2020 en fait on a vu massivement un
mouvement finalement de de réflexion et
de remise en cause de leur travail de
leurs conditions de travail du sens
qu'ils avaient dans leur travail et ça
continue en fait de s'étaler ce
phénomène appelé grande démission a
d'abord été remarqué aux États-Unis
4 millions et demi d’américains ont
quitté leur poste pour le seul mois de
novembre 2021 un record absolu
en France la DARES une des antennes du
ministère du Travail a observé un pic de
démission au début de l'année au premier
trimestre 2022 on a constaté 520 000
démissions sur l'ensemble de la France
donc 470
000 qui venaient de CDI c'est un niveau
qui est historiquement haut qui avait
jamais été constaté le taux de démission
rapporté au nombre d'emplois et lui au
plus haut depuis 2008 selon la Darest
les Français reviennent rapidement sur
le marché du travail il profite
seulement d'une économie dynamique le
marché du travail est un peu plus
favorable aux salariés puisque la
demande est forte ils peuvent négocier
leurs conditions de travail leur salaire
donc on s'attend à voir un peu une
déformation favorable aux salariés dans
les mois qui viennent dans certains
secteur moins attractifs ces concessions
des employeurs ne sont pas suffisantes
suite à la grande démission la
restauration a conclu un accord de
branche pour augmenter les salaires
malgré cela 200 000 salariés mental
appels
Alexandre est le gérant de cette
brasserie parisienne aujourd'hui une
serveuse est malade
voilà un peu de sport on retour aux
sources chocolat chaud combien il
cherche à embaucher des serveurs
supplémentaires on partirait sur deux
mais avant la saison au printemps on
était sur une capacité de 3 à 3
saisonniers qu'on n'a pas qu'on n'a pas
vu qu'on n'a pas vu et qu'on avait les
années auparavant avant le covid
selon Alexandre difficile d'embaucher
dans ce contexte de grandes démissions
les serveurs font jouer leur salaire
pour pouvoir se pour pouvoir trouver
d'autres maisons qui payent plus mais
encore une fois ces personnes-là faut
les remplacer et aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas les remplacer parce qu'on a pas de
profil qui se présente donc on fait tout
pour garder l'équipe on est en place on
augmente les salaires on essaie de
réorganiser le travail en français sur
trois songes et en ce moment à quitter
son poste avec près de 200 000 emplois
créés depuis le début de l'année le
marché reste dynamique mais la crise
énergétique pourrait mettre un coup
d'arrêt à cette vague de démission pour
2023 la Banque de France envisage une
récession comme un scénario possible